what's the best way to ask someone do
you just call them or email them and
just say hey I'm doing this project and
I'd love you to be a part of it the best
way to ask someone depends on what your
what your documentary subject is for
adultery one it was it's almost better
to ask them outright because you're
gonna be asking them really really
personal questions too
you don't want to start your
relationship off with them with kind of
flattery I should say you know you don't
you just want to be like this is odd
honestly this is what I'm doing and I
want honest answers from you so I'm just
gonna be honest upfront as opposed to
lighter documentaries where you know it
depends on what it is if it's a
documentary where you're just following
one person then obviously you'd probably
want to build a friendship or hopefully
have a friendship with that person for a
long time before hey I'm gonna shoot you
on camera and it might not turn out the
way you like and also you're you know if
it's a good movie then it's gonna have a
screening and you're gonna be on camera
and there's gonna be 200 people watching
you you know you probably want to have a
very trusting relationship with that
person by then so that's very it's all
relying on who the documentary subject
is and unfortunately there's no real
blue book or blueprint of how to how to
judge that from a person if you're doing
the kind of documentary where you have a
bunch of subjects
you